Así es han sido varias las muestras de
pésame el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador
y dirigió un mensaje de condolencias al
pueblo a los pueblos del Reino Unido por
el fallecimiento de la reina lo hizo
extensivo a familiares amigos y miembros
de la casa real y canciller Marcelo
ebrard también pues expresó su su pésame
y posteó una foto de la reina en blanco
y negro de su juventud en el senado de
la República guardaron Un minuto de
silencio eh por este fallecimiento y la
embajadora de México en Reino Unido
también se sumó a las condolencias dijo
que es fue una mujer profundamente
importante y fuente de inspiración para
muchas generaciones y posee una foto de
la Reina Isabel segunda en de México en
la en el sitio arqueológico de Monte
Albán en Oaxaca esa foto corresponde a
la primera visita que hizo Isabel II en
1975 era el mes de febrero el 24 de
febrero día de la bandera en México
cuando la Reina Isabel y su esposo
visitaron por primera vez México de
hecho fue la primera visita de un
monarca británico al país era Entonces
el país gobernado por el presidente Luis
Echeverría quien la recibió en el zócalo
de la Ciudad de México con un
espectáculo
artístico con una congregación de
ciudadanos que pues corearon e hicieron
porras y también Hicieron una
composición una especie de mosaico con
el rostro de la monarca y del presidente
mexicano con lemas de amistad le dio una
cena en Palacio Nacional pero la reina
también hizo una visita por varios
estados de la república visitó como ya
decía Oaxaca la Zona Arqueológica de
Monte Albán y también Yucatán el sitio
arqueológico de uxmal Las crónicas de la
época relatan que la reina pues visitó
durante estos recorridos visitó en
mercados de artesanías en donde compraba
cerámica compraba también mercados
populares y sobre todo bueno de gustó el
platillos típicos mexicanos como el
pipián que es una especie de salsa de
distintos chiles también los tlacoyos es
una especie de tortilla rellena de
frijol en fin fue una visita de acuerdo
con los reportes de la época pues muy
cálida la reina expresó su satisfacción
por este encuentro y también escuchó por
ejemplo la voz del tenor Pedro Vargas
escuchó la canción La cucaracha en fin
fue muy colorida Esta visita a México y
posteriormente hizo una segunda y última
visita en el año de 1983 ya más discreta
pues era un ambiente distinto México
estaba atravesando por una crisis
económica pero también recorrió varios
estados recorrió varios puntos
turísticos Acapulco Puerto Vallarta Baja
California Sur presenció El avistamiento
de ballena gris todavía en 2015 que
durante la visita del entonces
presidente Enrique Peña Nieto a
Inglaterra pues la reina recordó estas
visitas dijo que tenían ingratos
recuerdos ella y su esposo de las
visitas a México de la Reina Isabel